CALGARY OUT THERE AS THE CALGARY
FLAMES LIKE STARTING QUICKLY.
THE
[ Horn Blaring ]
HAS SEEN ENOUGH.
[ Horn Blaring ]TCHIE HAS BEEN D
THAT'S GONE
FACEOFF.
FINALLY CLAIMED BY THE OILERS.
BACKLUND AROUND FOR MANGIAPANE.
AND NOWEEPING THEM OUT
THERE, HE CHANGES THE MATCHUP.
LOOK AT COLOLGER WHO ALMOST SPOD
THIS BATTLE OF ALBERTA PARTY.FEE
CALGARY FLAMES.
THEREWHAT A PLAY BY CONNOR MCD,
THE
NUGENT-HOPKINS A LITTLE SLOW ON
THE DEVELOPING PLAY BUT LOOK AT
ON THETO CHEER SO FAR TONIGHT.
DU A THREE-ON-THREE,
AND STONE JUST A LITTLE
CAUTIOUS.
DIDN'T CLOSE THE GAP QUICKLY.
LOOK
OFF, A CHANCE FOR CECI IN FRONT,
AND NUGENT-HO FOR A SPLIT
SECOND BUT FINALLY IT'S ZACH
HYMAN TAKIKI
LEAFS AND LIGHTNING COMBINED FOR
TEN IN A LAND, GET
THE BLOCK AND CHANGE AND ALLLL
HERE'S JARNKROK, BANKS IT IN
FROM MANGIAPANAN LINESMAN, NOT O
CATCH MCDAVID.
NOW HE COMES ON FROM THEACK TO E
AND THAT SHOT BLOCKED IN FRONT.
STILL
KINS THROUGH CENTRE.S MATTW
TKACHUK WITH